welcome to this video playing shy mud
shot but poorly checkmate from Venezuela
and playing a double fianchetto Kings
Indian BB n [ __ ] ok principles to
symmetrical English type of position ok
I can also castle first that's both
possible maybe I should have canceled
it's probably a bit more precise but not
a big deal really let's see let's guys
pretty high rated 2337 Jesse doing ok
let's check him I can play just might
see three right so there any drawback I
don't see it Mme can take 94 I can take
94 that that's stupid takes Queen takes
Bishop takes and I'm losing material
silly silly 94 hmm yeah this is how we
also lose games simply overlooking
little tricks ok I have to continue you
with 22 minor pieces let's see
yeah the pieces are somewhat active at
least no but he probably is able to to
open up things relatively quickly he
needs to open up the position for his
rooks mostly I tried to provoke some
weakness him this allows me to play age
five really okay I think this this is
something I should should welcome f5 I
go back to f3 I guess I can taking it's
not a good idea i'm probably i can take
b7 huh test grabbing this now this just
opens up stuff for him i guess this is
better
ok so I would open up open this up now
hmm yeah I'm unpinned here 95 would be
nice to to play maybe just castles now I
don't don't think that the H file is is
is that that important if he takes our
plane 95 hmm and this is not not so easy
to play from like
probably it probably is a win somehow
but it's not totally easy to play right
on d5 s-sir is a good piece let's see
me65 Knight f6 cabinets just cover this
for the moment and see on there
that's a strange move he wants to go to
h6 right or we're okay let's play this
first
five and the man aged 40 page one that
cannot be really what what black ones
wow really okay that's surprising and
then he returns the exchange what is
this what is the plan hmm I mean f6
cannot really beat the solution this
even Bishop takes f6 if everything else
fails yes that I can just take this
probably and then he has rook takes
really okay so so this one right
and ce4 hangs and lots lots of stuff is
hanging now yeah talk about a strange
game that's I can take the rook but
maybe I have something better you I evil
play you for okay but let's just take
first we stick it on e4 with a check
unfortunately Bishop here then the Queen
cakes hmm
ah tough position I really tough
position he gets this back here look
f-4s norma threat and Knight f6 he's
ignoring most of my threats really check
King age age I have this check as well
and I have I can hear can take it to
take with check out
check
check-check
should therefore Luke age eight is the
plan and I don't see what he's doing
against it should be quite dangerous
well what the game laughs resigns here
after this after i blundered plundered
the opening and 93 is really atrocious
yeah i mean i don't have anything anyway
but something like this I probably must
flip or bishops is three but chances
this is certainly okay for black
something I don't know something like
this this I just blundered I just
blundered to you daddy for I saw it I
saw it too late the problem is of course
that after this yeah here I'm losing
everything so the only thing that I can
still play is this and here blackest is
really just winning it's a matter of
some precision but somehow he he
stumbled into problems this is probably
okay each for I really thought h5 should
be played just make sure that there is
nothing that age five is not not coming
didn't see a big problem with that I
will probably cancel now always tried to
put a night to d5 but yeah I mean like
it's just winning here I mean it takes
take some time and and maybe some
patients as you don't win like
immediately but it's a queen for two
pieces came here this stood probably all
wins but we are getting getting to a
situation where at least it is it is
tricky the compass on minus 3 minus
forward here already a few like have
practical chances young I don't know it
still it still seems to to win here for
example and the if if I the system is a
mistake he can I yeah this is a good
solution he can just do this yeah that's
very convincing black gives up an
exchange but now I'm sorry he gives up
the Queen to be an exchange up and this
is a pretty trivial win I have no
counter plane they all came and this is
blood this is a blonde up to Bishop e3
he just basically blinded the whole
group here before cam difficult now I
went through t 1 this is a agreed upon
by the comp and this is the next mistake
of six runs into ruka for this while
threatening anyway in some check now
look see one is also strong jam stronger
even so okay I I think this is this is
enough i have little time and i want to
easy moves to play check check check
german TI rook rook t forget it he
cannot he cannot defend at all yeah very
lucky win after this opening okay thanks
for watching